did you never drink or do drugs ever
never drank never did drugs you were
pretty hooked on coffee though right
yeah it's a problem I I read he almost
got fired from fire Twisted Sister being
too caffeinated yes I was called in for
a band meeting and they go dude you got
to cut back on the caffeine the C and
I'm looking at literally a guy who's
going to AA meeting every night the
other guy's got a freaking beer in his
hand it's only like 10:00 in the morning
someone else has white powder underneath
his nose and I said wait a second my
coffee drinking is bothering your drug
and alcohol use and they told me if I
didn't cut back they were going to have
to get rid of me how much coffee were
you drinking am I
worst three full pots so that's like 15
cups H I love the big one at Dunkin'
Donuts so two of those a day plus three
full pots